i've i'd kind of half-assed watch rick
and morty previously but now i just
watched like the first season it's such
a brilliant show i i like
i did not understand how brilliant that
show is and obviously i think in season
one is where the butter robot comes
along for
just a few minutes or whatever but i
just fell in love with the butter robot
the sort of the
that particular character just like you
said there's characters you can create
personalities you can create and that
particular
a robot
who's doing a particular task
realizes
you know
this like realizes that's the
existential question this the myth of
sisyphus question that uh camus writes
about it's like is this all there is
because he moves butter
but you know
that realization that's a that's a
beautiful little realization for a robot
that my purpose is very
limited with this particular task it's a
beaut it's it's humor of course it's
darkness it's a beautiful mix but so
they want to
release that butter robot
but something tells me
that to do the same depth of personality
as cosmo had the same richness it would
be on the manufacturing on the ai
on the storytelling on the design it's
going to be very very difficult it could
be a cool sort of
toy for rick and morty fans
but to create the same
depth of
existential angst yeah that the butter
robot symbolizes is really
that's the brave effort you succeeded at
with cosmo but it's not easy it's really
good
you can fail on almost any one of the
kind of dimensions and like uh and yeah
it takes you know
yeah unique convergence of a lot of
different skill sets to try to pull that
off yeah
on this topic let me ask you for some
advice
because uh as i've been watching rick
and morty i i told myself i have to
build the butter robot just as a hobby
project and so i got a nice platform for
it with treads and and there's a camera
that moves up and down and so on
um i'll probably paint it uh
but
the question i'd like to ask there's
obvious technical questions i'm fine
with communication the personality
storytelling all those kinds of things
um i think i understand the process of
that but how do you know
when you got it right
so with with cosmo how did you know
this is great like or um something is
off like yeah is this brainstorming with
the team
do you know it when you see it is it
like
love at first sight it's like this is
right or like i guess if we think of it
as an optimization space
is there uncanny valley we're like
that's not right or this is right or are
a lot of characters right yeah
we stayed away from uncanny valley just
by having such a different well like
mapping where it didn't try to look like
a dog or a human or anything like that
and so uh
you avoided having like a weird pseudo
similarity but not quite hitting the
mark um but you could like just fall
flat where just like a personality or a
you know character emotion just didn't
feel right and so it actually mirrored
very closely to kind of the iterations
that a character director of pixar would
have where you're
running through it and you can virtually
kind of like see what it'll look like we
we created a plug-in to where we
actually used like like maya the sim you
know the animation tools and then we
created a plug-in that
perfectly
matched it uh to the physical one and so
you could like test it out virtually and
then push a button and see it physically
play out and there's like subtle
differences and so you want to like make
sure that that feedback loop is super
easy to be able to test it live um and
then sometimes like
you would just feel it that it's right
and intuitively no and then you'd also
do we did user testing but
it was very very often that like the
into like if we found it magical it
would scale and be magical uh more
broadly there were not too many cases
where like
like we were pretty decent about not
like getting to it you know geeking out
or getting too attached to something
that was super unique to us um but
trying to kind of like you know put a
customer hat on and does it truly kind
of feel magical and so in a lot of ways
we just give a lot of um
autonomy to the
character team to really think about the
you know character board and mood boards
and storyboards and like what's the
background of this character and how
would they react um and they went
through a process that's actually pretty
familiar but now had to operate under
these unique constraints um but
the moment where it felt right um
kind of took a fairly similar journey
than like a as a character in an
animated film actually it's quite cool
well the the thing that's really
important to me and i wonder if it's
possible
well i hope it's possible pretty sure
it's possible is
for me
even though i know how it works
to make sure there's sufficient
randomness in the process yeah uh
probably because it would be machine
learning based
that i'm surprised
that i don't i'm surprised by certain
reactions i'm surprised by certain
communication maybe that's in a form of
a question
um were you surprised by certain things
cosmo did like certain interactions
yeah we made it intentionally like
uh so that there would be some surprise
then like
a decent amount of variability in how
he'd respond in certain circumstances
and so in the end like it's um
this is this isn't general ai this is a
giant like spectrum and library of like
parametrized kind of emotional responses
and an emotional engine that would like
kind of map
your current state of the game your
emotions the world the people are
playing with you all so forth to what's
happening um but we could make it feel
spontaneous by creating enough
diversity uh and randomness uh but still
within the bounds of what felt felt like
very realistic um to make that work and
then what was really neat is that we
could get statistics on how much of that
space we were saturating um and then add
more animations and more diversity in
the places that would get hit more often
so that you stay ahead of the um you
know the the curve and maximize the uh
the chance that it stays feeling alive
um and so but then when you like combine
it like
the permutations and kind of like the
combinations of emotions stitched
together sometimes surprised us because
you see them in isolation but when you
actually see them and you see them live
you know relative to some event that
happen in the game or whatnot like it
was kind of cool to see the combination
of the two and um uh and not too
different in other robotics applications
where like you get you get so used to
thinking about like the modules of a
system and how things progress through a
tech stack
that the real magic is when all the
pieces come together and you start
getting
the right emergent behavior um in a way
that's easy to lose when you just kind
of go too deep into any one piece of it
yeah when the system is sufficiently
complex there is something like emergent
behavior and that's where the magic is
as a human being you can still
appreciate the beauty of that magic of
the fine at the system level first of
all thank you for humoring me on this uh
it's really really
uh fascinating i think a lot of people
would love this i i'd love to just one
last thing on the butter robot i promise
in terms of uh speech yeah
cosmo is able to communicate so much
with just movement and face
do you think speech
is too much of a degree of freedom
like a speech a feature or a bug of uh
deep
uh interaction
emotional interaction yeah
for product
it's too deep right now it's just not
real uh it would immediately break the
fiction because the state of the art is
just not good enough um and
that's on top of just narrowing down the
demographic where like the way you speak
to an adult versus a way speak to a
child is very different um yet a dog is
able to appeal to everybody um
and so right now there is no speech
system that is like rich enough and and
subtly realistic enough to feel
appropriate um and so we very very
quickly kind of like moved away from it
now speech understanding is a different
matter where understanding intent that's
a really valuable input um
but
giving it back requires like a you know
way way higher bar given kind of where
today's um uh world is and so
uh
that realization that you can do
surprisingly much with
uh either no speech or kind of tonal
like the way you know wally r2d2 and
kind of other characters are able to um
it's quite powerful and it generalizes
um across cultures and across ages
really really well i think we're gonna
be in that
world for a little while where it's
still very much an unsolved problem on
how to like make something it touches on
kenny valley thing so if you have legs
and you're a big humanoid looking thing
you have very different expectations and
a much narrower degree of what's going
to be acceptable by society than if
you're a you know robot like uh like
cosmo or wall and you can or some other
form where you can kind of like reinvent
the the character speech has that same
property where speech is so well
understood um in terms of expectations
by humans that you have far less
flexibility on how to deviate from that
and lean into your strengths and avoid
weaknesses but i wonder if there is
obviously there is certain kinds of
speech
that
uh
activates the uncanny valley and breaks
the illusion faster so
i guess my intuition is
we will solve certain
we would be able to
create some speech-based personalities
sooner than others so for example i
could i could think of
a robot that doesn't know english and is
learning english right yeah those kinds
of personalization where you're like uh
you're intentionally kind of like
getting a toddler level of uh speech so
that's exactly right so you can have
like
uh
tie it into the experience where uh it
is a more limited character or you
embrace the lack of emotions as part or
the lack of sorry dynamic range in the
speech kind of capabilities emotions as
like part of the character itself and
you've seen that in like kind of
fictional characters as well um but
that's why this podcast works and
yeah like and you kind of had that with
like um i don't know i guess like you
know data and some of the other yeah
like um but yeah so you have to and that
becomes a constraint that lets you
meet the bar um see i i honestly think
like also if you add
uh drunk
and angry
that gives you more constraints that
allow you to be uh dumber from an nlp
perspective like there's certain aspects
so if you modify human behavior like
let's just so forget the sort of
artificial thing where you don't know
english toddler thing
we if you just look at the full range of
humans
i think we there's certain
situations where we put up
with uh like lower level of intelligence
in our communication like if somebody's
drunk we understand this issue that
they're probably under the influence
like we understand that they're not
going to be making any sense anger is
another one like that i'm sure there's a
lot of other kind of situation yeah
maybe uh yeah again language loss in
translation
that kind of stuff that i think if you
if you play with that
uh what is it the ukrainian boy that
passed the touring test you know i'll
play with those ideas i think that's
really interesting and then you can
create compelling characters but you're
right that's a dangerous sort of road to
walk because uh you're adding degrees of
freedom that can get you in trouble yeah
and that's why like you have these um
big pushes that like for most of the
last decade plus like where you'd have
like
full like
human replicas of robots really being
down to like skin and like kind of in
some places um
my personal feeling is like man like
that's not the direction that's most
fruitful right now um beautiful art yeah
it's not in terms of a uh rich deep
fulfilling experience yeah you're right
yeah and no way creating a minefield of
potential places to feel off uh
and then and then you're sidestepping
where like the biggest kind of
functional ai challenges are to actually
have you know kind of like really rich
productivity that actually kind of
justifies a you know kind of the higher
price points and that's that's part of
the challenges like yeah like robots are
going to get to like thousands of
dollars tens of thousands of dollars and
so forth but you can imagine what sort
of expectation of value that comes with
it um and so that's where
you want to be able to invest the
the the time and uh and depth and so
going down the full human replica route
um
creates a gigantic uh
distraction and really really high bar
that can end up sucking up so much of
your resources
you